congratulations recently married the
beautiful Valerie there I am there you
are from behind there was an explosion
about to go off and I enveloped her nice
that's good yeah
so anything has anything changed cuz you
guys been dating for a while now that
you're married anything change in the
relationship well you know it's
interesting anybody here that's found
love or even though lonely people can
listen as well whenever I'm in a
relationship including now a girlfriend
forever is the idea that you need to
look out for love transfers I'm actually
really happy to get this out there when
someone says I love you you got to make
sure they mean you because I think a lot
of times we're all victims to what I
call love transfers hmm like you'll be
sitting on the couch you'll be watching
let's say Conan and all of a sudden you
get very hungry out of nowhere like
blood sugar drops to zero look yeah
blood sugar drops to zero
yeah throat closes in on itself on
television yeah and you get very very
hungry you pick up the phone you're
gonna order a pizza and you start
getting really happy that a pizza it's
coming has it ever happen yeah it's just
like a little secret you have where
you're like huh yeah I want pizza yeah I
know I know it's all good good guy money
I don't want money I want pizza
yeah and he gets so flooded with joy
that a pizza is coming you hang up the
phone you turn to your wife the
girlfriend lover and you just go I love
you so much
the love needs to go somewhere you love
pizza you love me you mean me yes don't
think about a cheesy treat yeah
you